play the clip
of what what i think would be one way to
help unify america and i want to get
your thoughts
and i also want to kind of give you an
idea what's been happening since then on
what kind of messages i started getting
with this cafe can raise the volume see
where the volume's at
i'm gonna pull my stats of your message
here too
and then uh go ahead and press play but
i'm deeply concerned with how divided
america is today and i think there are
only two people that can help us unify
america with one of them being former
president
barack obama and the other being yes
former president
donald j trump and this is why i'm
putting five million dollars of my own
money
two and a half million dollars to
president obama two and a half million
dollars
to president trump to agree to do a
long-form interview to discuss
ideas with only one thing in mind to
help unify
america having said that president obama
president trump let me address why i
think you ought to consider doing this
number one i think if we were to look at
america as a left wing
and a right wing i think the voice of
the left wing today is still president
obama and the voice of the right wing
today
is still president donald j trump but
when i think about the two of you i
think about two people who both
love america they have different ideas
but i think both of you
love america and i also see today
whenever i see a husband and wife that
are about to go through a divorce we see
signs of a divorce you see it six months
before 12 months before eight months
before
and you try to do whatever you can to
save that marriage but you kind of see
it's coming i think the world if they're
watching us
china iran russia is seeing a great
divorce could potentially happen with
the united states of america
and what can we do to save that marriage
obviously they would love to see us get
a divorce
but i think amen both of you admire
abraham lincoln once said the following
we are not enemies but friends we must
not be enemies
though passion may have strained it must
not break our bonds of affection
the mystic chords of memory will swell
when again touched
as surely they will be by the better
angels of our nature
i don't know if you'll agree with this
or not but i think the world thinks the
two of you are enemies and it doesn't
make any sense to have two presidents of
the greatest nation in the world
to be enemies what do you think would
happen if the two of you sat down
together
how would china iran or russia react to
that why does this matter to me see i
have four kids i just had my last kid
two weeks ago brooklyn ivy bed david and
i'm in the hospital looking at this baby
saying to myself
your daddy's dreams became a reality
because of this great country called
america with the flag behind me
but are your dreams going to become a
reality is this the same thing as it was
42 years ago 22 years ago i don't know
i'm gonna do my part i can't run for
office
but i'm gonna do whatever i can to unite
this great nation here so if you're
watching this
and if you agree to this i would love to
schedule the time and folks if you're
watching this and you want to see this
become a reality
share with everybody you know
i don't bother if you're watching this
i'm curious i'm watching the commentary
right now put a thumbs up if you'd like
to see this not whether you believe this
could happen or not put a thumbs up if
you'd like to see this put a thumbs down
if you don't want to see this at all you
don't think it would do anything to help
reunite america gerard your reaction to
something like this if
it were to happen well first of all you
know you're welcome um
for uh the usage of my backyard there uh
no no beautiful choice you got there i
gotta tell you yeah beautiful home i
appreciate that
uh it's fine you know we we had the
cabana open for you
uh what do i think i think a a
discussion
not a debate uh an actual discussion
between these two folks
on on how we got to where we are and
really just focused on solutions of how
we can get
forward past this would be the greatest
thing to
ever happen in the history of american
media i cannot think of any time in my
life
that two opposing factions sat down
and one took accountability for how we
got here because they both
have a hand in where the nation is right
now and then
propose solutions going forward you know
it's it's like getting two gang leaders
to the table the only thing that i could
kind of think of
was back in the day when i was young and
this is something a lot of people aren't
going to know about but it's part of my
irish heritage so we were aware of it
it's when clinton got the crown and the
ira to sit down together
and say look we got to stop we got to
stop blowing things up in belfast we got
to stop putting bombs in
in garbage cans in london right and that
has the whole ulster question
that had a a massive effect on the world
the eu
doesn't exist today without first that
that domino
of falling right so i i think any time
there can be a daytime to any time that
there can be communication between
two warring factions and make no mistake
about it the left and the right the
politicians in dc are
at war with one another make no mistake
about it
anytime that they can sit down and talk
and walk us all brat back from the brink
i think it's it's a necessary thing and
and are you really going to put five
million enough in this five million
bucks
for real is that that's not a gimmick
like 100
100 5 million bucks why would i say to
not do it
dude that's awesome i hope i you know
yeah i hope that they
i hope that they are man enough to do it
i hope that they are man enough to sit
down in their beliefs
and say this isn't about me this is
about us
and i hope i i hope it gets to them and
i hope that they see this and i hope
that their first reaction is like no way
and then i hope the people out there
and the valuetainers because you guys
hit up my dms and i know how persuasive
you can be
i hope you guys are blasting these
people i hope you're blasting their
camps
i hope you find out who their campaign
managers are because that's the truth if
you want to talk to these people you
find out who their campaign managers are
and you blast them with this and you you
the squeaky wheel gets there
who wants to see this happen who doesn't
want to see this happen that's the real
question i mean if you
think about like if you look at the
messaging and when this went out
yesterday i got a lot of calls from
people saying you know i shared this
with my group and everybody said you
know i had people saying why the hell
would
obama ever sit across a you know con man
like trump
and then there were people that said why
the hell would trump ever sit down with
somebody that says conniving
i mean it's like on both sides there are
some people that cannot get that
division
out of their minds to see this thing
take place but who do you not think
wants to see this happen and who do you
think wants to see this happen
i i look we're a government
as as you pointed out of identity
right and identity politics is the tool
of the left at the moment
to run on identity whereas the tool of
the right is still
running on ideas but ideas and then
identity is a close second and it
creates a division
so i don't think pelosi wants to see
this pelosi's been spending
they would have to change so pelosi
doesn't want to see it
because they've spent so much time
generating so much momentum
taking advantage of all the unrest and
all of its various forms of the last 14
months
i don't think she wants to see this
because she would have to she would have
to concede certain points
so i don't think the left is going to
want to see this because
they would have to concede points and
they are the volatile side of the
argument
in terms of the incendiary part of it
whereas the right
tends to be the reactive part of it
they're usually reacting to the
incendiary
there's sins on both sides but i i don't
think that the hard
left leadership wants to see it the uh
i don't know if i could even say his
name it rhymes with uh
uh c singh uh ting would not like to see
this happen
he's he spent a lot more than five
million dollars to rip this country in
half
and he's almost got it they've almost
got it
we we what let me let me let me ask a
question a different way i got a guy
yesterday i'm trying to get a seat
he messaged me right now it's phone
number i'm texting him uh
uh uh to get him on here but here's here
look at it from a different standpoint
this text to you look at it from a
different standpoint here's a question
say it happens okay let's just say it
happens let's say we have the meeting
set up
and trump and obama are sitting right
across from one another long form
interviews sit down okay
now when i first announced this and we
were talking about remember when this
was this was uh
a few days before fourth of july when i
said i want to do this you're like pat
this is crazy you know this is
and we went i don't know until what time
it was midnight when we were processing
this together we've known about doing
this for how long now since one o'clock
in the morning one o'clock in the
morning this is a week before fourth of
july so go whatever today's date is
go to then that's about five weeks and
it happened off the cuff we were at the
kitchen
uh uh you know just having a
conversation i said i'd like to see this
take place right
but say this takes place and they're
sitting there together
my only reason why i think this
first thing you said you think this
could take place i said i think this
could take place
but i said there's only one person that
wouldn't want this to happen
and you said who wouldn't want this
thing to happen i said oprah winfrey
why wouldn't you want why wouldn't it
because the first thing is going to be
if oprah's camp gets ahold of this
they send it to her she goes to abc and
says let me do this interview why would
i let somebody else do the interview
i think a long form interview in a
format like this to sit down and have
the right questions to be asked to hear
both of them go at it if that were to
take place
how do you think the world's going to
react what do you think positively it's
going to do to america if it actually
did take place
and how will it do anything any negative
impact on who so how will the world
react
what positive impact will it have and
what negative impact will it have
yeah to me first of all it'd be
cathartic like
i'm done with debates these these canned
questions and the sound bites i'm done
it's not
it's not an actual debate a sit-down
conversation where they actually could
call each other
you know see each other as as equals see
each other not you know not necessarily
as adversaries but two wings of the same
bird
look we talk about it on this podcast
all the time i just want to live in the
same reality with people i disagree i
don't need to agree with everybody i
just want to live in the same reality
that they live in
there's people when i was up in new york
i'm like dude we don't live in the same
reality
when there's people looking at bill de
blasio the mayor of new york
telling us the voluntary phase of this
vaccination is over
and people being like okay good that's a
good thing and i'm like what we're not
living in the same reality
that the government just said that
they're gonna come to your door kick the
door down
and shove something that you don't want
inside your body i mean what
i mean what what's the difference
between consent and what's the
difference between
you know and not it's consent what's the
difference i'm not gonna use the r word
and get this thing
but i'm saying that's it the difference
between sex and something else is just
consent
that's all it is so now these guys are
gonna take your body
they think they own you the government
does not own me
the government does not stay on this
topic tell me about this topic though
who tom who who how would the world
react to it
if this were to actually happen well
this happened in my lifetime and
you would have been very very very very
very small but
uh one of the gentleman's probably one
of the nicest
and most uh integris people ever to be
in the white house
but he was a very ineffective leader in
president which is jimmy carter
jimmy carter got the camp david
peace accord pulled off and the world
watched in
shock as he took menachembegan and anwar
sadat i believe it was
to camp david and got them to agree on
things and agree to peace
and there are many people including me
i'm not part of politics but
everything i've read it cost anwar sadat
his life
he was assassinated later but they
a world watched in absolute
shock and awe in a good way as the two
sides came together and if kai can find
the pictures of a camp david peace
accord
going back there before it was right
before 1980
it's happened before in our lifetime
where two avowed enemies got together
and the world was shocked and inspired
there they are look at that picture they
were they were actually
laughing there was relationship look at
there you can't
fake that that was not modern-day faked
images pat
those images there are men who now have
some semblance of a relationship
as a result and it started as a sit-down
brokered by jimmy carter who is in the
middle of breaking the us economy
another story
brokered by jimmy carter to get these
two folks together so what do you think
would happen
i think you'd have this guy you're
you're not on a
camp david stage and nobel peace prize
and all this stuff
but i think that if you truly got it
together
there would be a percent of people that
look at it like this
and would be really inspired by pat
look at the far left the first picture
look at him there with jimmy carter hand
on his heart lower
lower left okay before now look at
that yeah which two guys
don't look like they want to be there
and then look at the other picture
i i believe we can make progress on this
and i think we've seen it
right here in our lifetime when you get
sides together
and you can have some sort of a dialogue
and move it forward something
something can happen there'll be parts
of this country that don't want it to
happen
gee that that that want to undermine it
all
but i i think it would be a moment that
i think would be
strong what what would you hope to get
out of it i mean what would you hope to
get out of it what would you ask them
how could you get them off of their
talking points
how could you they're so entrenched in
their talking points how would they just
not take the money
and use it to further messaging that's
already out there they're all over the
place
somebody asked me a question they said
you know why don't you give the two and
a half million dollars to charity i said
i don't
the money can go anywhere that wants to
go to if they want to give it a charity
or if they want to keep it matter of
fact
uh i'm i'm going to keep raising money
to see if this money needs to get higher
for us to be able to make this happen
whether it's
somebody said why don't you announce
that anybody that matches your 5 million
they're actually in the room when the
interview takes place so if somebody
wants to match five million
what if we get ten people that put up
five million now we got 50 million
dollars now we're raising some money
what if
people are donating a thousand dollars
two thousand dollars five thousand
dollars
to be able to make this thing happen and
then eventually we get the attention i
don't know if we're announcing a hundred
million dollars
you might be a millionaire you might be
able to afford 100 for 100 million yeah
if if we get to 50 million dollars a pop
if we get to a point where we're raising
that kind of money to get the attention
of it you want to give it to charity
what do you want to give it to president
obama you want to give it to illinois to
help some kids out great
hey president trump you want to help
some of the guys do what you want do
what you want to do with it
yours charity whatever it may be here's
here's what i do believe here's what i
do believe
i believe this is going to happen i
fully believe this is going to happen
the only thing with this
on whether it's going to happen or not
is whether people want to see an oprah
winfrey do the interview
or if people want to see a podcast do
the interview
that's the real difference i'm going to
go raise the money i'm willing to have
that money being
brought up i've sat in a lot of
different conversations in my life where
people who didn't want to talk to each
other and i've always seen
99 of issues that you have
will be resolved when you face off with
each other because at the end of the day
even the person you can't stand the most
if you spend a few hours with them and
you talk you'll eventually realize
we have a lot more in common than we
actually think in common
right if you actually think about how
many things barack obama and donald
trump
differ in how many think you think it is
how many things is it
say stuff that they fully disagree with
is it a thousand things
is it a hundred things is it fifty
things it's probably nuanced within
those things but what i'm saying to you
is how many thinks you think it is
is it is it family you think neither one
of them value family
you think neither one of them uh value
uh
the ability to communicate a message you
think neither one of them value
the ability to work hard you think obama
became a two-term president by now
working his tail off on the campaign
you think trump became who he is today
but not wanting to go out and work his
tail off to make money
what what what values do they do there's
there's hundreds they're on the same
page with
the idea becomes let's identify what the
two of you guys agree with
what are some areas that you disagree
with and how do we get here
and what are both of you willing to
commit to you chose to go into public
service nobody encouraged you to go into
it
you chose to go into public service what
do we need to do to bring this thing
together because at this point of the
game
it's no longer about you know whether
america is going to be the greatest
country in the world forever that's not
what it's looking like right now you got
countries like china that are catching
up
you got countries from many different
places that are not intimidated
of america like they once used to be i
think if they sit down together
and they go from one state where we're
talking and asking some questions about
how we got here
and then it gets to a point where i just
pause and i say can you guys just talk
the two of you and we're going to watch
what questions do you have for each
other
i think there's got to be an approach
where they talk to one another and then
we ask the questions
and see where that goes but i can tell
you by the time it's over with
if it's done properly the world's going
to look at it and say
this is not good because if it becomes
them against the world this is not a
good thing if it becomes them against
the world could that happen could it not
happen i don't
know but all i'm when a lot of people
say it's a terrible idea one guy said
it's a narcissistic idea you have no
idea how this is a narcissistic idea
to come up with this you know when you
think about an idea i got people that
said i don't know why nobody else
thought about this before i don't know
why nobody else has announced this
before
the reality of it is if we can unite
is america worth uniting the answer is
what
hell yes if it's not then you give me
your alternative
if somebody says terrible idea what's
your idea
what do you suggest doing so if you
enjoy this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye